[Music]
[Applause]
Jason Garrett NBC football night America
analyst and Notre Dame football analyst
he will be on the call uh Noah eagle and
uh Zora Stevenson Saturday the Fighting
Irish and that's uh 2 30 Eastern on NBC
in peacock but that'll be 7 30 local
time here in Dublin forgot all about
that so uh Paulie a little drum roll for
uh Jason Garrett
[Laughter]
what is that that you're playing it's
called a Barum I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it correctly it's a it's an
Irish traditional drum and I've gotten
in a three minute construction I know
you're really good
you're solid you're a natural uh hi
coach how are you I'm doing fantastic
you're kidding me we're in Dublin okay
you got to get your team up I had some
problems with for tea I saw that he
moped a little bit yesterday and I you
know I got on him a little bit a little
bit yeah I mean I'm old school I'm
Lombardy I mean I'm gonna get after you
a little bit here but uh if you were
gonna pick up the spirits get guys
motivated how did you do that
you know there are a lot of different
ways you can do that Dan as you know
um you know Marcus Freeman talks about
one play One Life
you know if you think about that let's
go to the next play yeah uh I thought
you did a good job kind of getting them
going that way okay I mean it was a
little bit kind of a harassing technique
all right thank you coach
glad you're recognized I'd like to be
more positive right is that also a
YouTube song
[Applause]
[Laughter]
did you yell at Players speaking of that
we got lost yesterday and one of the
issues in in Dublin which I love is
it's hard to find the name of the
streets and and talking about you you
two songs they're up on the side of the
building yeah streets have no name yeah
no don't say it will was that another
Marcus
so I'm empathetic I really am so you got
lost
um yeah we kind of it took us a little
bit to get to where we're going
yesterday all right did you yell at
Players when you coached
um at times you have to raise your voice
but in general you try not to do that
okay but what what is going to bring out
the anger in your voice if I'm a player
uh uh I think repeated mistakes
stuff the guys should know like full
start
well more like we went over this
yesterday we went over it again last
night and you're doing it again
you know it doesn't seem like that's
been an issue here with fritzy right oh
no this has been going on for 20 years
yes 20 years
yeah coach did you ever have because I
once used this tactic
um did you ever have a player who kept
making mistakes and you'd reprimand them
they'd be like you're right
I'm not I can't get it
would they ever just own it and just say
I can't get it and I don't think I will
get it then you just gotta do this right
okay okay because I once got out of
getting fired from a job by I I just
accepted the criticism and said you're
right you're doing a horrible job and it
disarmed my employee my boss to the
point where it was like a Jedi mind
trick and I I he said you're on thin ice
and I'm like I should be I'm not good at
this job yeah but I always wondered the
different coaching philosophies if you
wanted to get my attention if you had a
normal voice and you were like speaking
direct to me then you got my attention
but if you yelled I just tune you out I
had no interest in what you were it was
just noise but if you were like hey and
I was called Golden Boy when I was in
college so I for obvious reasons well uh
it wasn't a good thing by the way I I
thought it was a good thing when the
coach goes uh my golly golden
and it was a negative but he would yell
at me and I just tuned him out
did you tune out do you got yelled at
when you played yeah I I think you when
you're a player you have to understand
that it's not it's not really how
they're saying it's what they're saying
so if you can sort through kind of the
noise of it and figure out why is this
guy getting so mad at me what's the
point what's the Nugget in here I think
that was always the approach but when
you're a coach I mean I don't think it's
a great thing to rely on screaming it
guys but you know Jimmy Johnson talks
about if this guy falls asleep in a
meeting he'll cut him but if Troy falls
asleep in a meeting he would nudge him
to wake him up you know I was in that
meeting when Jimmy went over that and
and it's it's a revelation for a player
when a head coach stands in front of the
room and he says okay guys I'm going to
try to treat everybody fairly but we're
not going to treat everybody the same
and he goes through this the player was
a guy named John Roper who was the
linebacker he's a linebacker force it
was a heck of a player played at Texas A
M but came to us and was kind of on the
border and he falls asleep and Jimmy
gets rid of him and then he he kind of
revealed to the rest of it Troy
I'd go over and nudge them you know and
so that's a wake-up call for everybody
in in the building to say okay wait a
second I can't do what they do
I gotta listen and if you're the third
string quarterback like I was you better
you better be there early and stay late
uh I was looking at your career 11
touchdowns five interceptions is that
right
that's a long time ago okay give me your
NFL highlight like that you think back
and you go you know what
well the Highlight was to be part of
three Super Bowl teams but I'm talking
about when you were quarterback yeah
when you were playing I got a chance to
play on Thanksgiving Day okay against
the against the Packers okay that was
1994 and Troy gotten hurt Rodney Pete
USC guy had gotten hurt yeah so I got a
chance to play and we were really good
they were really was the Packers Harve
and Reggie White and those guys they
were really good and uh the game wasn't
really good for me in the beginning but
then eventually we got it going and we
beat him and it was a big deal what was
it like because Reggie White might be
the greatest defensive lineman I mean
he's certainly in the conversation
greatest defensive player of all time
but you get to the line of scrimmage
do you want to make sure you know where
Reggie White is oh absolutely and we
played against Reggie when he was in
Philadelphia then he goes to Green Bay
it's like we can't get away from this
guy
um but the interesting story is you
remember Larry Allen Larry Allen one of
the greatest linemen of all time it was
his rookie year and uh we had a guy
named Eric Williams who played right
tackle uh Eric was hurt and so Larry
Allen as a rookie had to play right
tackle against Reggie White
and and Larry Allen is 14-time pro
bowler I mean he's a remarkable player
in the conversation to be the best
alignment of all time Reggie White is
throwing Larry Allen around like you've
never seen Russia's up the field he does
this thing called the hump move he
throws him over it's like that's Larry
Allen right there you know and uh
it was bad in the beginning of the game
Reggie White's knocking passes down he's
sacking me and uh he very famously
doesn't swear he's a minister yeah so
he's laying on top of you and he's like
oh you're doing great you really are
I didn't mean to say hell you know
better defensive player or more
impactful LT or Reggie White
oh great question
um
I think LT was probably more destructive
I mean he changed the game you had to
change blocking but Reggie White if he's
not there is right behind him yeah uh
incredible player we're talking to Jason
Garrett uh he'll be on the call coming
up Saturday night Notre Dame Kristen's
their season how good is Notre Dame
I think they have a chance to be really
good uh you know I did the games last
year so I got a chance to get to know a
lot of these guys I think Marcus Freeman
will be better in year two just like
anybody would be uh he's building his
program putting his stamp on it uh they
got a lot of good young players they got
some veteran players on defense but the
the big factor here will be the the
emergence and the arrival of Sam Hartman
a lot of experience as a quarterback
awake force a lot of success he's 24. he
is
it's really 24. it's amazing
um yeah he acts like it he's really
mature he's a leader and Stetson Bennett
was what 25 yeah but Chris wanke was 28
yeah when he played and at that level I
mean what's the difference between an 18
19 year old as opposed to somebody who's
23-24.
well just picture it I mean this guy's
played you know started so many games
he's throwing 110 touchdown passes in
college football and uh so he comes into
this place it's a new environment the
transition will be interesting for him
but he has so much experience under his
belt and we had a production meeting
with him over the summer and he's just
mature I mean it reminds you of an NFL
player and uh and so I think that's
going to have a real positive pervasive
impact on this team I'm curious when you
were coaching uh your philosophy with
rookie quarterbacks playing them in the
preseason that like Sam Howell with the
commanders he's not a rookie but it's
his first year starting got to play you
know what 40 plays Anthony Richardson is
he going to play should he play Bryce
young CJ Stroud what was your philosophy
and would it be would it be changing now
with today's quarterback well it was
very noticeable to me that the Kansas
City Chiefs who everybody thinks they're
just a Razzle Dazzle outfit and all that
kind of stuff their head coach is an old
school guy
if you go to a Kansas City Chief's
practice the shirts are tucked into
practice they run more than anybody and
oh by the way it's the first preseason
game and number 15 is under Center he's
playing so I'm four guys playing I think
you need to play there's only three
preseason games I don't care who you are
there's an acclimation period in
football so certainly if you're a young
player you gotta play it's different to
playing a game than it is in practice
and I know regular season will be
different than the preseason I get that
but playing in a preseason game with
your uniform on against another opponent
seeing a variety of things that you
haven't seen in practice it's valuable
and you know we had Dak Prescott in 2016
and Tony Romo was going to be our
quarterback but he got hurt Kellen Moore
was our backup he got hurt now Dak is
our starter and thankfully we played him
a lot in the preseason and ended up
winning 13 games for us so uh if you're
a young player you need to play and I
get the risk of injury and all of that
but it's pro football that comes with it
I wonder about Romo because he he was a
really good quarterback if he doesn't
get hurt or he adds his Super Bowl wins
the Super Bowl being a Cowboy
quarterback I wonder if he's a Hall of
Famer a borderline Hall of Famer or a
Hall of Famer in your opinion oh I don't
think there's any doubt that his numbers
would suggest that but you know as we
all know you get judged by the playoffs
in the Super Bowl and uh you know there
are a lot of there are a lot of great
players who don't feel like they've
reached that next Echelon because they
weren't part of championship teams but
do you think that that's should be the
like Eli Manning I don't think it's a
Hall of Fame quarterback
but I think he's going to get into the
Hall of Fame and he he won two Super
Bowls but his numbers during the regular
season he would suggest to use a good
quarterback yeah you know that's the
measuring stick uh whether you agree
with it or not if Walter Payton had
retired before the 85 season
he's still a Hall of Fame one of the
greatest yeah but we don't we don't hold
running backs or any other position to
that it's coaches and quarterbacks yeah
nobody says well how many uh you know
Calvin Johnson didn't win any playoff
games uh see a Hall of Famer yeah that's
a great Point nobody questions it now I
know the quarterback has more of a say
there but I it feels like that's the
bottom line and I don't know Philip
Rivers Hall of Famer in my opinion he is
absolutely Eli Manning
I think he will be a Hall of Famer yeah
do you think he should be a Hall of
Famer
it's a tricky thing you know you know
Deion Sanders was a teammate of mine for
five years and and as we all know Dion
is this amazing guy incredible athlete
maybe the best I've ever been around and
he has this wisdom about life and
you know we're at the hall of fame a
couple weeks ago to do that game and I
kept thinking about Dion's line that
they're letting a lot of guys in here I
need my own room you know
but I'm okay with that yeah if you go in
first ballot I have no problem with you
having the top floor yeah like the Gold
Room just called the Golden room and I
think that's that's the means if you're
a first ballot Hall of Fame yeah you're
kind of different than everybody I'm
okay with that yes will you you got a
question
you're a big big advocate of Ken
Anderson yes I am right getting into the
Hall of Fame yes I am perfect example
he's someone who never won went to a
Super Bowl right lost to Montana but has
amazing but if he beat Montana He Go
he's in if Matt Ryan is Matt Ryan a Hall
of Famer
I think he is
eventually yeah
the tricky part about the whole thing is
how many balls you think Lynn Swann
caught in his career 400 yeah less than
500 yeah okay it's an error where
they're not throwing the ball very much
but if you think about the impact that
Lynn Swann had on football had on
championship teams it's as impactful as
anybody so the numbers change different
than baseball yeah baseball you hit 300
you're going to be you're going to be a
Hall of Famer football the game has
changed so it's hard to say from this
generation to that generation we're
going to compare numbers and all of that
so that's a tricky element to this thing
too so I do think winning being part of
the winning team in your generation
should carry a little extra weight okay
you being a former quarterback and being
a former coach
you can have Belichick or Brady to start
your franchise
um
you know Bill Belichick's the best coach
ever
the the trophy could be named after him
okay very easily but is there a butt
coming the impact of that quarterback on
that franchise and on football uh is is
significant you think about what he did
20 years there all the success they had
and oh by the way I'm going to go to
Tampa they were 7-9 last year and now
I'm gonna go win the Super Bowl with
them
um it's pretty rare
um at the end of the day you need
quarterbacks to win so I'm going to say
just by a smidge okay all right I'll
take the quarterback okay fair enough
but having said that Belichick's the
best that ever won did he draft Brady
you did yeah okay so he saw he saw what
was there wow maybe well okay took him
in the six yeah it's not like he goes we
better get him in the third
or or second right it was like uh oh by
the way yeah in fact skinny kid from the
combine will take him
we'll use our six round pick yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean I I guess I can say
that's part of the genius but I think
that'd be stretching a little bit I
think he lucked into Tom Brady
fair fair okay totally fair thank you
take 199. yeah 199. uh have fun on
Saturday night yeah it's going to be fun
yep I look forward to it we'll be there
uh if they let us in we still got a few
more days here in Dublin so I don't know
we might uh hey coach can you do you
have a line on getting any Ottawa Rough
Rider swag for me yeah okay I do I know
people up there Landsdowne Park but they
didn't they change did they change their
name
there's Rough Riders and then didn't
somebody change their name to the like
Black Knights or yeah black they did
something right you know there are eight
teams up there and they're two Rough
Riders but yeah there's a distinction
okay one of them is one word Rough
Riders the other one is Rough Riders oh
yeah yeah so now it makes sense now
I see it I clear it up for you coach
thanks for joining us and uh you can
hear coach coming up on Saturday night
it's Notre Dame and navy can I just have
one more second here okay can you tell
me the training you did for the snowball
scene in elf yeah you know
thank you thank you for asking Jason
magical
I worked with uh Tom house the
quarterback coach
former pitcher for the Atlanta Braves uh
and yeah we just we broke it down a lot
of film sessions yeah a lot of
Biometrics a lot of work with the bands
yeah yeah internal extra internal
external I like that yeah
great question great question thank you
uh have fun and thanks for joining us as
always uh we'll come back with our play
of the day right after this in The Dan
Patrick Show